let me start situating this topic in the
deep learning landscape
then i also got a chance to say a bit
about
my work
and did at dita
so there's basically two camps in deep
learning natural language processing and
computer vision
a typical nlp application could be to
well try to understand maybe some legal
documents some contracts and classify
the different sections of a contract and
perhaps identify those which may not
have a legal standing
some examples of computer vision
applications could be to look for
defects in some manufacturing defects in
some technical components
or remote sensing that is analysis of
satellite energy so say look for some
small scale mines
so those by the way were all projects we
developed for clients at dita
now um
those two
camps have their very specialized set of
tools of models uh
and they work
very well
but of course those are far from the
only interesting problems we could
tackle with data science so it would be
very interesting to have
more generic more flexible
deep learning models
and this is exactly where graph neural
networks come in
so to
to guide our discussion i'll pick the
sample use case which is also inspired
by a project we have
which is to
understand documents in tabular format
so what we see here is
well the picture of a an invoice or a
bill
and this document has some headers some
addresses some dates
and then the interesting part is this
table right it has the table list some
products or services and these things
have like a description
then some prices some quantities okay
and what we would like our
machine learning model to do is to
classify the words in this document
appropriately so say
this is a date
where this was issued so this would be
one of the metadata and now each entry
in the table
we are identifying this description part
as such maybe there's some more fine
grained information here this
description has some units
and then a price and then a quantity and
so it goes
right so
a standard language model
which only looks at the text
sequentially
for such a model this maybe this
quantity 2 here would come completely
out of the blue right because it follows
some information that is not really
related to quantities so we would like
um to have a model which
um
yeah is able to to to get this broader
view of the
of the the data
all right so uh here is a typical
information extraction pipeline so we
have some input data some input
documents
we apply some preprocessing to it so
maybe in that case our input was just
pdf files and we
we pre-process in a suitable way
such that the data can be fed to a
machine learning algorithm some number
crunching algorithm and then out of this
comes a
some useful prediction from the model
okay so where could graphs potentially
enter in this picture and there's two
places
so in the pre-processing step we would
like to take this document and
or this data and encode it
using a graph
in a way that meaningfully captures the
structure of the of the input data
and then in the second step this number
crunching instead we would like to use
an algorithm
that then can consume and make good use
of this graphi uh
data we got
all right so then this is now a quick
agenda for the remainder of the talk so
i'm going to start in this part of the
pipeline discussing graphs and graph
neural networks
then as an interlude i'll make a quick
comparison with the convolutional nets
which
are like the bread and butter of
computer vision and the hope here is
that
probably most people have some
familiarity with continents so you can
you have a point to to compare to
understand things and maybe you can even
understand continents a little better
after you see this
and then at the end i'll go back to our
use case and this is going to illustrate
a bit how the pre-processing would look
like
all right very good so what is a graph
a graph is just a picture like this one
which you make out of dots which we call
nodes or vertices and arrows connecting
the dots so those we call edges or links
or relationships
okay
and so in a in applications typically
this graph the nodes and edges will come
with additional data some some labels
okay so say if this graph represented a
social network where the vertices
represent people and the edges maybe
represent payments
people made among themselves so our
notes would be labeled by the name or
other attributes of the person and maybe
our edge would be labeled by a number
which is the amount of the money
transfer
okay
and then just as a quick heads up
this is one version one definition of a
graph there's many variations if you
pick up a random paper something
slightly different might be meant so
maybe
a double parallel
edges like this one are not allowed or
maybe loops are not allowed
or maybe this edges can be considered
not to be directed
okay
but in our example here that that would
be
our notion of graph
and
i want to give you a mathematical
definition not to be precious about this
but because there is a slight difference
between what a graph is and what a
computer representation of a graph is
and it's good to we we have to have
clarity about this when working with
graph algorithms
and also it's a it's a fun thing to look
at so so what is a graph or if to be
very precise we could call this a
directed pseudograph
so but i'll just say graph so graph is
given by a set of vertices hello denote
qrdv then a set of edges that are
denoted curly e
and then two functions from e to v that
are called source and target okay so in
my example the set of vertices would be
a b c d and e
the set of edges would be this small
letters b q
up to v
and then say if i take my edge p here
its target its source is the node a its
target is the node b
and if i look at my edge
v its source is the node e and its
target is also e
okay
so that that's that's it that's what it
is and then i already made this comment
that in applications uh words and edges
come with labels so the way this is
modeled is as functions from
v the set of vertices to some set of
vertices labels so maybe each vertex has
a string attached to it or some
more complex data structure and same for
the edges
all right so now how do you represent
the graph in python or any other
language
so the first step is to pick an
enumeration of the vertices and edges
and that's why i changed my notation a
little bit so
before my nodes were a b c d and e and
now i'm calling them v zero v one which
will be three and v four okay i just
number them put an order and then
similar thing for the edges okay
and then okay there's a couple
alternative ways to represent the graph
uh one of them is as an adjacency list
okay so that's a list of pairs of
numbers this list has one entry for each
edge in my graph okay so say the the
zeroth entry of my list
describes the edge is zero okay
and that entry is a pair of numbers in
this case the pair zero one and that
indicates the fact that the source is g0
and the target is v1 okay
so then it goes right so the last entry
in the list describes my last vertex my
last edge e6
and it has a source and targets both v4
so the number the pair describing this
is four comma four
all right
so that's it
now going to this next step where we
want to attach
some data to vertices and edges right so
here's how this could be implemented
so we have to pick two types so suppose
we're gonna label the vertices with the
type node t and the edges with the type
edge t right so then my class graph
would be a little data class like this
okay depends on these two types and then
okay then we have a list called nodes
which is just it's just a list of
objects of type node t
list of edges which is a list of objects
of edge t type and then an adjacency
list like i just described okay which is
a list of pairs of integer integers okay
and this two source and target methods
is just what i just described right so
if i want to know what the source of the
k-th edge is i look at the k-th entry of
the adjacency
list and then look at the first that's a
tuple right and then i look at the first
item in there
good
all right so now we can
get to graph neural networks and to
discuss that uh i want to just fix on a
fairly simple
possibility so first of all fix one kind
of problem out of many we could pick and
i'm going to discuss the node
classification problem okay so what this
means is
we give us input a graph
and out of it we want a labeling of the
vertices let's say it's a binary
classification problem so it's just a
function from the vertices to
zero and one okay
or alternatively you give me this this
this graph with
enumeration vertices and then
you just have to output a list
of numbers zero and one the i entry
corresponds to the i vertex
okay
and i want to make two more simplifying
assumptions one is that my nodes are
labeled with a tensor okay so some
tensor some some
array of numbers of a fixed size
and my edges are labeled by
an enumeration type okay so this just
means i have a list of
possible edge types it's a final list
not too big
okay so say if this was a social network
then maybe each of these tensors would
be some numerical encoding of various
attributes of a person
and then maybe we could have a few
different types of relationships between
them so say two people can be friends or
they can be co-workers or
relatives okay so this will be the three
entries of my enumeration type
all right so now we can i can describe
for you a possible uh
graph
neural network layer okay and what i'm
doing here is
pretty much taken out of this paper
which is one nice bridge
but okay so here is how this works so so
my gnn layer is just some some
uh layer in the in in a model which
takes a simple graph and outputs a new
graph okay
this new graph
has okay it has the same topology so it
has the same nodes and
and edges
uh i'm not changing the edge types
either okay but for each node i'm
computing a new feature tensor okay
and so here is
uh well a formula you can use for that
and
uh okay don't worry if if you can't
follow 100 percent of this especially if
it's the first time you see anything
similar but i want to just read this
formula step by step so
we see what's going on
all right so what is
y v y v is the output feature tensor of
the node v okay so say let's focus on
this guy here node v4 okay so i would be
describing this tensor here the output
feature tensor of v4
okay
and
this is computed as follows so it's a
it's a summation and the summation has
one term for each edge incident so
incoming coming into v okay and i call w
it's source and e the edge itself okay
so say
in the case of before the sum would have
three terms one corresponding to e4 one
to e5 and one term corresponding to e6
okay
now let's see how each of these terms
computed
so what i'm supposed to do is to take
the input feature tensor
of the nodes which is the
the source of that edge okay so let's
focus on this edge here
its source is v2 so i look at this
tensor here which is the input feature
tensor of v2 okay
and then i multiply this tensor by a
weight matrix which is part of the model
it's a learned weight matrix okay
but then little detail there is actually
one different weight matrix for each
edge type so what i should do is i look
at okay i'm looking at edge four i
should see what's its type is
it's one of this possible enumeration uh
elements and there is one little weight
matrix corresponding to each edge type
okay each enumeration element so i pick
that that appropriate
matrix okay then i multiply those things
i multiply by a normalization factor
and then i add these things all up okay
let me discuss a bit the normalization
factor it's basically the degree of the
node so the number of incident edges
except that i only focus on the incoming
edges so i just look at how many edges
are ins coming into v have v v4 in this
case as target and moreover i restrict
to those that have the same type of the
edge e
okay
all right so this normalization factor
in this case would make a huge
difference but you can imagine say a
social network it's very typical that
some nodes are have just a few
connections some nodes have potentially
thousands of connections so a
normalization of this kind is important
for things not to blow up okay
and then last step i apply a
non-linear activation function could be
a relu a sigmoid whatever we like okay
so that's it that's a formula for a
perfectly fine and functioning
uh
gnn layer okay
so just to mention a bit uh all about
okay so maybe a an alternative way to
think of this is you could imagine that
each node so each node in this vertex
has its okay this incoming of input
feature tensor and it has to compute a
new tensor and the way it does that is
by receiving a message from each of
these uh arrows that are incidents to it
so that would be a way to think about it
so the message with this guy and then
the node receives all these messages and
it uh uh
yeah totalizes to
incorporate those messages into a new uh
value okay
and so we could have many variations on
this scheme so what where here we have
this matrix multiplication we could have
some maybe some attention like thing
where
this value depends not only on the
inputs
feature tensor of the of w so the the
origin of this arrow but also on uh
x v so the
the input tensor of the node
in question itself right
we could uh
totalize this this tensor using a
different formula maybe some max
instead of summation so many variations
are possible here it's a very flexible
scheme
all right so now we can go to our
comparison with convolutional networks
and so let me start with a quick recap
on convolutional networks so this is an
algorithm for images right and the way
this works is we have an image each
twitch pixel in the image we have an
input feature tensor so in the first
layer it would be just intensity of red
green and blue channels okay
and we want to compute for each pixel a
new feature vector and so the new
feature vector the output switch vector
of this pixel at position i comma j is
computed as follows so we look at a
little patch of say three by three
pixels around it okay
so for each pixel in this patch we look
at its
its input feature tensor
then we multiply that by a matrix which
is learned as part of the model and
there is one different matrix for each
position in the patch okay
and then we add these things all up
there's nine uh
vectors and then we apply some
non-linear activation function okay so
the summation is over this indices k and
l right between minus one and one so
each pair k and l locates one
position of the three by three patch
okay
all right so that was a recap and now
what on earth has this anything to do
with graphs
so here is a little graph representing
this three by three patch okay so in in
this in this piece of a graph
each node represents the pixel
and then the arrows represent this
relationship of being a neighbor okay
and moreover since uh well
two pixels can be made neighbors in one
of eight different directions right
which are these cardinal directions
those are the labels i attached to my to
my edges right
okay and now next slide i'm going to
replace the formula here for the
continent
i'm just going to rewrite it using this
graphic syntax from
the previous slide okay and so here it
is so let me read again this for you
okay
so this is a formula for the output
feature cancer of the pixel p which is
the center here okay and the way i
compute this is the following i look at
all
all the neighboring pixels right so each
neighboring pixel is
a node in my graph which with a link to
to p right and moreover this
neighboring relation is of one of these
four eight types right one of this eight
cardinal directions
so
for each of these pixels i look at its
original feature tensor it's xq and i
multiply by a matrix the matrix depends
on which position this is right so it
depends on which kind which cardinal
direction this this neighbor is coming
from
and then i add these things all up okay
and moreover the
uh well the the input feature cancer of
p itself also plays a role right so this
is also accounted for this so i could
include a loop a self edge on around p
with the label o
and then this term would be included in
the summation would be subsumed i just
didn't do this to keep the picture a bit
clearer
all right good so this would be a
picture representing the entire image
okay
so that's it uh
so uh of course a graph neural network
can take in graphs of arbitrary shapes
while conv nets is specialized shapes of
this graph
but that's fine so continents are a
particular case of graph
layers
all right so then now we can go back to
our use case so which was about
information extraction from tables
uh so
uh all right so here it is the idea is
we receive a table it can be like this
table it can be a completely different
layout like this one okay but from this
page we make a graph
and in this graph each word is a note
and then we have a bunch of edges which
are added in the following way so for
each word we divide the page into these
four sectors the stuff that is above
below and switch side okay
and then we look at the nearest
neighbor of the word in each of these
directions okay so say above the nearest
neighbor is this zip code 1645 it would
be represented by this node and we add
an edge linking them
and of course this edge has a label
which says okay it's a neighbor above
and we kept going like this so say maybe
next step uh one two three four five has
his neighbor above the word south so
this would be this guy
as a neighbor to the
to the left would be the nearest would
be the word states so this would be this
guy and and so on okay
and that's it that that's how we make a
graph of out of the page and
in a table this will link words that
belong to a same line same column and
this is where our model can learn
interesting
information
all right so here just um
a possible end-to-end model architecture
which is pretty much what we used in
this use case
so we take in these pages we collect all
the words we link the words to make a
graph and now we need to associate uh
useful features to the word right and
there's basically two categories of
things you can do first you can look at
the
uh
geometric features so the coordinates of
the bounding box of the word so this
makes
some features and then there's features
from the
text of the word right
and then you could come up by hand with
some stuff like oh is this a purely
numerical word is it alphanumerical
is it
in in a list of common common words like
is it the name of a month or
or some common header word
or you could try to be fancier and
design a character cnn that learns on
the fly useful uh
features
anyway for each word you concatenate
these things you get some maybe
reasonably big feature tensor
maybe pass a linear layer to normalize
the size and then you feed to a couple
of gnn blocks just like the one i
described except maybe you add some
dropout some batch normalization
some skip connections stuff that is
meant to help with convergence in the
training time
and yeah maybe a skip connection to help
the character cnn converge and then at
the end you add a feed forward block a
soft max and out of this comes
out probabilities for each word to
belong to each of the categories
uh each of the classes into which you
want to classify
so that's it
so this is pretty much the model we used
in this project um out of about a
thousand training documents we got a
model with an 88
f1 score
which is very good it's
better than a previous uh
system our client had in place where
where they had to manually label each
type of um each new table layouts that
appear to them
it also worked better than a
prototype that we had developed earlier
which was based on random forests so
that was a
pretty
big success for us
and that's it so just to finish up um a
couple words about implementations so
there are a few different libraries
available out there i think you could
all find it by googling
if you want to read up on this topic
uh okay maybe some more popular uh
places uh will not will be a bit
disappointing so the page for the
wikipedia page for graph neural network
exists since earlier this month but then
one suggestion i can give you is to just
go to the documentation of any of these
packages i particularly like the pythag
case
it lists uh
papers with
for which they provide implementation so
if you go to the papers it would be a
good place to to delve into the topic
so yeah so with that i
like to thank you